Apple's new M2 Pro and Max MacBook Pros
are fast while getting extra battery
life but there's just one little problem
they're still being built on the same
second generation five nanometer
technology as the M2 Chip sadly not
three nanometer and not even four
nanometer which is basically just third
gen 5 nanometer that the a16 chip is
built on so in this video I'm going to
talk about the implications of that and
what it's going to mean for you by
analyzing the chips to see what we
should expect in terms of the
performance overheating GPU scaling
which is a huge problem with the M1
family of chips and I'll even explain
how these machines could get much better
battery life in the real world we're
also doing a worldwide giveaway of a new
Macbook Pro and Mac Mini and all you got
to do to enter is subscribe enable
notifications and comment down below
which you can do on each new Mac video
that we make for more chances to win and
we're gonna reveal the winner on
February 1st so don't miss out on that
video but before I talk about the
implications of 2nd Gen 5 nanometer I
want to show you guys some analysis of
these new Chips as you can see right
here high yield on Twitter labeled some
of the different parts of the M2 Pro
champ right here in the center we can
see the a performance cores along with a
memory cache for those cores we also
have an AMX co-processor on each end now
containing blocks of nine Matrix units
instead of four per block on the M1 Pro
chip which should help with matrix
multiplication tasks over to the left we
have the efficiency cores and now
there's four of them double than before
with their own AMX units as well and
just like the M2 Chip they are now
larger and more powerful just like we
had on the a15 chip and I'll explain
what that's going to mean in just a
minute at the top we have some dye area
for the i o which is used for things
like the ports and on the right we have
four more i o spots with some
Thunderbolt 4 controllers behind behind
them for the Thunderbolt ports and even
the HDMI port as well and that's why we
have the display engines below them
highlighted in teal and then below that
we have the 16 core neural engine which
is the same one from the M2 Chip with
15.8 trillion operations per second
compared to 11 on the M1 Pro then below
that in blue we have the 19 core GPU and
you can even count each little core from
core 0 to core 18 with the miscellaneous
area containing things like extra caches
and whatever else and if you're
wondering why there is 19 cores instead
of 20 it's actually not because of
bidding which means disabling a faulty
core so they can still Salvage the chip
instead of throwing it away which is
what they're doing for this 16 core base
model M2 Pro chip right now the 20th
core has actually been completely
removed and replaced with a bunch of
other transistors that I haven't been
able to confirm just yet and yes you can
even see this missing core on an actual
photo of the M2 Pro from the Apple event
but I actually have a theory about what
this is for which I'm going to explain
in just a couple of minutes getting back
to the diagram we have the SLC cache on
both sides of the GPU cores which is
basically the system level cache which
is like temporary memory for data that
the entire chip uses and then on the
sides we have the channels for the lp
ddr5 memory modules which are housed
outside of the die right on the M2 pro
package and the really interesting thing
this year is that the M2 Pro now comes
with four Ram modules on the package
instead of two like on the M1 Pro which
could help with memory performance due
to having more memory buses but I'm not
really sure and then of course the M2
Max is simply a larger version of the
chip adding basically another copy of
the GPU cores SLC cache and memory
channels which connect to four larger
memory modules on the M2 Max package to
allow for up to 96 gigs of RAM and now
let's finally get into the actual
implications of the chips being built on
second gen 5 nanometer when the M2 Chip
was released I called it a stop Gap chip
because it ended up just being an
overclocked and tuned up M1 chip and it
wasn't just me because even Mark German
called it a stop Gap chip when I
interviewed him on this channel last
summer I even proved my own Theory by
showing that in a cinebench R23
benchmark test the M2 Chip consumed 36
percent more power to get only 13
percent more performance which screams
overclocked and don't worry notebook
check found basically the same thing in
their own testing worse CPU efficiency
compared to the M1 and both single core
and multi-core tests even though its
second gen 5 nanometer instead of first
gen which the M1 was based on so it
technically should be more efficient so
the only conclusion is that they pushed
the power to the limits to get that
performance increase not only that but I
ran the logic pro music production
stability Benchmark and found that the
M2 Chip handles the same or even less
tracks before the system overloads which
means that the extra power that they
pushed causes stability issues basically
confirmation that it's mostly an
overclocked chip and now we have the M2
Pro and Max which are once again on
second gen 5 nanometer so yes I do
believe they're overclocked stop Gap
chips which aren't going to be as
efficient as the M1 Pro and Max I fully
believe that the a16 chip and the entire
M2 family of chips were originally
planned to be on tsmc's three nanometer
process which was unfortunately delayed
due to all the supply chain issues so
Apple was forced to push these three
nanometer chips back to the a17 ship and
M3 three family of chips and give us
these overclocked and tuned up stop Gap
five nanometer chips for the time being
but anyway here's the problem with the
M2 Pro and Max being on five nanometer
again when we tested the M1 Pro and Max
MacBook Pros we ran into a couple of
issues the first one was the fact that
the 14-inch M1 Max model suffered from
Thermo throttling because it simply
couldn't keep itself cool and therefore
it saw a huge performance drop compared
to the 16 inch model a good reason for
that is because a 16 inch is of course a
lot bigger volume wise but when we tore
them down we discovered that the 16-inch
had a much beefier cooling system all
around which was one of the reasons why
the 16 inch with the M1 Max was slightly
heavier than the 16 inch with the M1 Pro
chip model so if the new M2 Pro and Max
ships are overclocked to consume a lot
more power to squeeze out that 20 CPU
and thirty percent GPU performance gains
then we could run into even more severe
thermal throttling issues than we did
before now of course we're going to be
doing a lot of testing with 10 different
2023 Mac models that we ordered so
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out but the upside this year is that the
14 inch now also is a bit heavier when
specked with the M2 Max which hints at a
beefier cooling system for the 14 inch
as well so hopefully Apple improved it
now the second issue I was worried about
in terms of second gen 5 nanometer was
GPU scaling which got exponentially
worse on the M1 Max and M1 Ultra chips
as you added more GPU cores in our
testing as you added more cores the
scaling got worse in terms of score or
FPS per core then we found the culprit
as you added more GPU cores the clock
speed on those cores went down which is
basically throttling but it wasn't
thermal throttling because as you added
more cores the temps actually went down
so it had nothing to do with overheating
something in the chip wasn't allowing
the course to run at full performance
almost like the chip literally couldn't
deliver enough power to the cores to Max
them out or something else and the
system was slowing them down and then we
discovered from an exclusive source that
the M1 family of chips were built with
an overlooked flaw in the tlb buffer
memory which would fill up quickly and
throttle performance if the app wasn't
properly optimized for the new tile base
GPU memory system which is almost all of
the apps that we tested and of course
that impacted the scaling as you added
more and more GPU cores but thankfully
we just heard some great news Apple has
apparently greatly improved on this
issue with the M2 family of chips so we
might actually see better scaling with
the the M2 Max and M2 Ultra chips this
by itself could make the higher end M2
Max chip perform much better than the M1
Max which suffered from the scaling
issues but wait it gets even better
ta-tec 15 on Twitter noticed that the M2
Max has a much larger area for the tsvs
right here in the center or through
silicon Vias it's basically channels
that go through the Silicon which could
be used for things like power delivery
or potentially connections to different
caches or memory so if the M1 Max and
Ultra chips had a power delivery issue
this could fix it and then hishnash on
Twitter also mentioned that this could
be part of the Improvement Apple made to
improve the tlb GPU scaling issue and on
top of that what if whatever is in that
last 20th GPU core is there to help
improve scaling as well and I actually
have a theory about this what if Apple
initially planned to make the M2 Pro
throw a 20 core GPU chip with 40 cores
on the M2 Max but they noticed that the
M1 Max and M1 Ultra chips scaled quite
badly so they edited the design of the
M2 Pro and Max to remove one core and
add something else in there that would
help with the rest of the GPU especially
scaling but one thing we know for sure
is that Apple decided that whatever is
in the place of the 20th core is more
important than the extra core itself and
it even looks like there are some extra
connections on the left side of that
area that connect to the larger tsvs
almost like it helps the bandwidth or
throughput somehow so with that said I'm
pretty hopeful that the new M2 Max chip
will scale better than before and now
let me get into explaining why the new
four efficiency core layout will greatly
help battery life with the M2 Chip we
noticed that it came with larger
efficiency cores that were actually
clocked higher than before as you can
see in this chart 2016 megahertz e-core
clock speed on the a15 chip compared to
1823 on the A14 which translates to the
difference between the M2 and the M1 so
the idea here is that the M2 Pro and Max
chips not only have faster e-cores but
twice as many so basically if you're not
doing high performance tasks the MacBook
Pro can give those to the e-cores
themselves to handle instead of having
to fire up the performance cores and
that saves battery life we even proved
this Theory by running both the M2 and
M1 chips in low power mode which relies
heavily on the efficiency cores and
there was a massive difference in
performance and battery life so that's
why the new Macbook Pros are getting an
extra hour of battery life on paper but
I think we might even see a bigger
difference in some use cases now with
all of that said do I think the M2 Pro
and Max ships are disappointing stop Gap
chips well they are stop Gap chips for
sure but I'm happy to see those hidden
improvements within the die and if Apple
did truly improve the GPU scaling then
this is a huge deal for the M2 Max and
especially the upcoming M2 Ultra chip
and I am expecting the M2 Max to Thermal
throttle in the 14 inch more than the
previous model but if they did in fact
beef up the cooling system for that 14
inch model then it's another piece of
good news and then finally even though
we don't have three nanometer yet the
extra efficiency cores should still help
in terms of real world battery life so
that's another positive so to wrap it
all up I do still think they're stopgap
chips but they are better than I
expected especially on 2nd Gen 5
nanometers so hopefully you enjoyed this
chip analysis and if you did let me know
down in the comment section below
especially to join the giveaway and use
the YouTube tagging feature below to
check out the new Macbook Pro that I
recommend and click subscribe to not
miss out on more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]